hallo zammen das ist Q&A zu min Repo
Leben im Wagen BesetzerInnen zwischen
Freiheit und Illegalität danke für mal
für ganze rückmeldige ich bin mega
überrascht wie viel rückmeldige das
ausgelöst h ich habe mich sehr gefreut
über die viele positive Feedbacks aber
auch die spannende Diskussionen wo
entstanden sind und auf es paar
Kommentare werte ich jetzt noch IG es
hat wirklich zwei Lager g die ein wo
gefunden h ja das sind schmotzer die
andere wo gefunden nein so z.B hat gesch
es ist nicht möglich überhaupt ein W
nicht zu finden und sie le ja für sich
mit wenig Ressourcen nutzig sie sind
keismotzer und der gagepart ist den
bewusst wird das Gesetz verletzt mega
unkorrekt Profiteure alles unter der
Flagge Freiheit die Zeit wird es Regeln
es wieso zi verschiedene gagerg finde
man muss gar nicht entscheiden sind Sie
es oder sind sie es nicht aber was man
nch wichtig ist s nmlich schbe wenn sie
keine Miete zahlen würde es mich nicht
wundern wenn auch die Steuerrechnungen
offen bleiben und do kann ich natürlich
sage sie sind in der Stad gemeldet heißt
sie zah aus stüre den hte Hans geschebe
dass das ja so eines großes arealsi und
sicher auch Platz hatte für ein
Container fürflüchtet die ich hat dazu
sagen dass es wirklich mal in der Plan
ist dass es den Unterkunft verflüchtete
die GT stad verschiedene zwischennutzige
in Betracht z h sich aber für keine
entsched V den und man muss dazu sagen
der Platz ist wirklich groß also
momentan teilt sich wagburg der Platz
zumb mit der Wage vom Zirkus Knie dann
hat schwiigfunde dass ich so auf dem
schmarotzere oder der Illegalität um
gritte bin und hat wie andere Sachen
spannender gefunden anstatt sich zu
frageen ob das jetzt legal ist oder
nicht Reportage BX setzen wir immer ein
Fokus und ein leidfrag wo mir verfolgt
ich habe mich in dem Film gefragt wie
ist das an me le wo jeder Z könte grumt
werde und nicht sind sie illegal oder
nicht weil das st wie fest sie Personen
sind natürlich nicht illegal aber dass
sie kein Vertrag h für der Platz und der
Platz besz ist nicht legal und trotzdem
hab ich auch andere Sachen spannen
gefunden und hat mein noch Platz z
gemeinschaftliche le wie sie Entscheid
trffet oder wie sie zu Lebensmittel
ich auch belüchte aber bin natürlich den
N verffegang find aber auch ganz viel
andere Aspekt spannend
denagoffen wurde wer in einer
Mietwohnung lebt kann auch jederzeit mit
einem Rauswurf rechnen das stimmt
natürlich bin won krift allerdings
natürlich der mirschutz und drum glaube
ich dass Wahrscheinlichkeit be der
wagburg schon größer ist dass sie weg
müss als wenn man
inbt dann is linea spannend und ich
würde definitiv nicht so wollen
spätestens mit Kindern braucht es
geordnete Strukturen und Sicherheit aber
eben jeder so wie er mag ich habe auch
mit der Lena über das greck sind auch
schon Kind auf Platz geh und gichzeitig
halt auch viele junge Frauen wo dann
schwanger wde sind wo mit ihr Partner
der Platz Verl h so wie das ja auch gemt
H mit ihr ichüber das Gre und sie mir
Gag dass sie sich schon wieder
vorstellen auf dem Platz le aber den
vielleicht in zwei WE und zum
allgemeinen Kind auf dem Platz sie mir
das gesagt ich glaube es Gott schon mit
me Kind auf WAG Platz ich fin ein immer
n sch
vorstellig wagplatz sie jetzt aber es
muss einfach mega Stimmen es muss
irgendwie von Infrastruktur
Stimmen fin mus der Gruppe mega Stimmen
W sie
Kind sind l viel sind sie mega viel
unterwegs vi im Winter
W mega viel so Aspekt was glaub jeder
groß
Wege wenn man Familie ist aber es h mega
viel Vorteil also man vermissen mir das
Mega das um ist und wie noch andere W
bringt die das
familifüge dann ist Thema auf Mini
Vorurteil Gleid wurde dass ich nmlich
ganz schön viel Vorteil und das stimmt
also mit dem bin ich aber wie auch
konfrontiert wurde dass ich w dem dre
hey krass du irgendwie dank du off und
das bin ich eigentlich auch aber B wir
auch mit me eig Vorteil konfrontiert
wurde und genau darum hab ich mich
entschieden das nachher im Film
transparent machen weil ich glaube dass
ganz viel l irgendwie so Gedanken und
die Frage sich gestellt wo ich mir
gestellt hab und ich drum eigentlich
gerade nur gut finde dass ich dir in
Stelle so dass es ganz viel andere l
auchört den gefunden dass es ganz viel
illegale Aspek wo ich nichtwis hab dass
man das mache z.B contain und ja mer vi
mal für den Input Container der Schwiz
gar nicht verbotte man DF einfach nicht
aufknacken und kein husfriedensbruch beg
natürlich strafbar und so der andere
Aspekt ich bin der Meinig dass ich immer
wieder erwähnt hab dass die das S
illegal sind das Polizeikontrolle
stattfunden es hat Anzeige und drum ich
wie gefunden ist das gerechtfertigge so
W ich es mache aber natürlich hat ich
z.B beim
containerfwies dass es Granzen geht den
hat gretafragt hey kann ich auch einfach
meinen Container dort abstellen wie
würden die Bewohner wohl reagieren und
da dazu finde ich hab ich noch spannende
die Unterhaltig mit der Lena K bim 3 wo
sie duuf egangen ist wie sie
Entscheidung get treffet wer be
inen sich hat der Gruppe chließen und
wer nicht red über lfrage V
personenpr oder wie mit men wohen was es
mega paradoxis selber der platzetzt
und jetzt aber trotzdem bestimmet wer
dürf da wne oder
zumindest Geminschaft me Platz
riesig im noch nicht so mega woh damit
oder so genau wie damit UMG will schlich
sind wir doch auch in Gemeinschaft und
wenn s miteinander irgendwie wohl
fühle
und das Media bestimme mit dem das mir
irgendwie das war vom Q&A wenn i noch wi
Frage oderk sch mir unbedingt die
Kommentar kann ich schriftlich n draf
und wenn nicht mehr wen verpassen D l
doch auf
verbi Kön all Filme streamen